[Music]  part cold war relic  part crumbling ufo  this mountaintop modern ruin was once  the epicenter of the bulgarian communist  party  the buzz ludza monument sits on top of  the balkan mountains 130 miles away from  the bulgarian capital  the monument was built to serve as a  grand hall for delegate meetings award  ceremonies and communist gatherings it  was only open for eight years until 1989  when the iron curtain fell and the  monument was abandoned  since then harsh winter conditions  looting and no formal upkeep has  resulted in a steady decline of the  building's structure  [Applause]  the soviet-esque star seen on the tower  was claimed to be seen from as far away  as the romanian and greek borders it is  three times larger than the star that  adorns the kremlin post-closure the  exterior of the building has been tagged  by graffiti artists including the  harrowing reminder  never forget your past  [Music]  you